well thousands of nevadans using food
stamps or EBT cards to get the goods for
Thanksgiving but one Las Vegas mother
says that won't happen for her family
this year EBT fraud wiped out almost all
of her monies according to her Ryan
Matthews shows us why she may not get
any of it back
while Shoppers stock up for Thursday's
holiday feast it took two hours to clean
it all out Janae Flores and Her Seven
kids are short thousands our oven went
out and we just bought a new oven
just so we can make a turkey you know
what I mean
and then we can't even do that the Las
Vegas native is a SNAP benefits
recipient a federal program that helps
low-income families get groceries
instead of food stamps she has an EBT
card but when she saw her account Sunday
4 100 were missing here's everything
look at all those charges 42 charges
from out of state ranging from 189 to
237 dollars each just days before
Thanksgiving they told me that someone
had to have stuck a device on top of the
EBT machine and when I swiped my card it
picked up my account number and the
digital sound of my PIN number and it
recognized everything she's one of every
seven nevadans or over 450 000 people
who depend on this program for groceries
every month and now following changes
from the pandemic even more money is
susceptible in this program to this
fraud she's now left with question now
what I haven't even got somebody to tell
me that they would investigate they tell
me they don't have the means to
investigate until then she's picking up
gig work in hopes of giving her family a
Thanksgiving but the money she's not
expecting back it's going to impact us
until the 7th of next month when we get
our reissuance you know what I mean
there's nothing we could do nothing
well when Ryan asked Nevada's Division
of Welfare and Supportive Services a
representative says to never share it an
EBT card or pin information with anyone
of course you're always asked to report
fraud as soon as you see it now Metro
Police say most of these skimming scams
happen in convenience or grocery stores